how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
mcu yesterday i did a video about moon
knight and it seemed like everybody
really enjoyed it moon knight is one of
the most anticipated disney plus series
that is coming and it's one that we
don't really know that much about
but that is about to change in a pretty
big way as we have learned some
epic information about moon knight
there's a lot happening right now and
like my title says it seems like we
could be getting keanu reeves as
mark spector aka moon knight so i'll
break down everything that you need to
know about this new report if you're new
and you love marvel be sure to subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a scarlet
witch funko pop i'm picking a winner on
monday
so today's report is coming from the
illuminerty.com and they have leaked
many things about marvel studios and the
mcu that have came true
including christian bale being in thor
love and thunder which of course ended
up being confirmed and as far as i know
they haven't been wrong with the report
yet
and yesterday they reported a couple of
different very important things
the first one is that development for
the moon night series has
officially begun now there are a ton of
disney plus series announced right now
there's everything in phase 4 and then
of course there's she-hulk and miss
marvel
as well but this makes sense considering
that she-hulk has officially been cast
and supposedly miss marvel has been cast
as well we just don't know who it is yet
but they do have their directors for the
show
so all of the other disney plus shows
have started production except for moon
knight
until now it's officially in development
and according to the illuminati it's
aiming to begin production by the end of
this year and
as soon as late november and as soon as
this starts we're going to start to
learn a lot more about the moon knight
series including who they're going to
cast to play mark spector but the
illuminati also has a report about that
as well
there's a casting call for moon knight
with a plot description of what the show
is going to be about so this is
essentially our first very real plot
leak
and the description for moon knight and
the plot of the series reads as follows
spectre was a former puglist mercenary
and cia agent he's double-crossed by his
boss
raul bushman after they find a
mysterious archaeological site
which bushmen plan to loot for his own
selfish means
near death spectre comes into contact
with kung chu
an egyptian moon god who offers him
another chance to live
in return for him becoming his avatar on
this world
spectre accepts the deal and is reborn
with superhuman powers he then returns
to the us
and accumulates immense wealth after
investing his earnings as a mercenary
and becomes the crime fighter known as
moon knight spectre also created
multiple identities including the alias
of millionaire stephen grant to
misdirect people from his mercenary
history
and jake lockley a low-key taxi cab
driver that helps him keep a closer ear
to the streets and criminal elements
mark spector aka moon knight is
described as a male between the ages
of 40 and 50. so for those of you who
know who mark spector is who know the
story about how he becomes moon knight
this is pretty much his exact origins
from the comics and pretty much what we
all expected so we know about how he
becomes moon knight and know about his
different personalities but the
illuminati goes on to report something
very interesting
they go on to say that this casting call
specifically notes who marvel thinks
would work for the role and they say
it's none other than keanu reeves now at
this point in time i do think it's
pretty much common knowledge that keanu
reeves has met with marvel studios i've
explained it before but for those of you
who may not know
marvel studios meets with really big
actors all the time and they meet with
them for pretty much every role and
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios himself has said that he pretty
much meets with keanu reeves about every
mcu project they do
keanu reeves actually met with marvel
studios about a role in captain marvel
the role of yonrog
now of course that role would ultimately
go to jude law but
they're basically just waiting to find
the perfect fit and
this role of mark spector aka moon
knight seems to be a pretty perfect fit
an actor between 40 and 50 years old
somebody who can be physically fit and
engage in hand-to-hand combat which i
guess keanu reeves is okay at
so i think keanu reeves would be a
pretty good fit for the role not to
mention
you have to have an actor that can play
kind of a darker role because that's
going to be the tone of
moon knight moon knight and kind of
phase 4 and phase 5 going
on are kind of going to be a little bit
darker a very different pace and tone
than we're used to
which in my opinion is actually a good
thing because we're still going to get
what we got with the infinity saga we're
just going to have more now especially
with all these movies and
disney plus shows there's a lot coming
to the mcu and there's a lot coming soon
so it's very
very exciting and it's very exciting
that kiana reeves could be making his
way to the mcu as
mark spector aka moon knight so be sure
to let me know what you think about this
casting if everything falls into place
and keanu reeves ends up being moon
knight do you think that would be a good
fit
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on
all of the latest mcu news for other
giveaways and updates you can follow me
on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
you